[Music]
in gotcha news gotcha
submitted by a graduated cylinder Oh a
fun trip to the world beard competition
ends an arrest for an alleged dark web
drug dealer
beard or beer beard that's a pretty big
beard [ __ ] connects to his [ __ ] scalp
leonidas yeah ever since I watched that
one Boy Meets World episode where
there's a character named Eric and he
like grows up really old and he just
becomes like a wise prophet and she's
like some fantasy world and he has his
beard and his name is plays with
squirrels and I just remember him taking
a lollipop out of his beard and licking
it and putting it back and I was like
that's [ __ ] genius I wish I had a
beer so I can hide candy in that's
disgusting you'd like save it for later
what did you put it in your hair I pull
that [ __ ] out of those paper stuck on
there mm-hmm
I don't think of that I was just very
straightforward like I need a beard yeah
so this dude he's a French 38 year old
named Jacques Cousteau oh yeah yeah
[Music]
that's his first name and their last
name is Valerie
Valerius steel Valerius steel hilarious
gal so this dude this 38 year old French
dude with a magnificent red beard oh I
like red bells already [ __ ] up man
had a regular beard you never got oh I
don't understand guys that are balding
but they could grow big beards I know
isn't that a [ __ ] tragedy it's
interesting it's like their body just
starts going upside down maybe I should
sleep upside down and get the hormones
back oh very blah yeah maybe she's it I
don't know it doesn't work like with you
guys cuz it's hard for you guys to grow
I know I'm just a hater like my pubes
are [ __ ] lush and I wish I could just
right here yeah my hair grows really
fast but it's sparse word sets do you
shave your face
oh I do I say but it's it's sparse
though Oh like right here I'm a Viking I
wish I could take the veggie burger
right here I'm like a dandelion it grows
like crazy yeah any wildlings down there
Valerius he's being accused of being a
drug kingpin on the dark web acting as
an administrator for a dream market
which is a marketplace for illegal
narcotics including cocaine heroin
methamphetamines
counterfeit consumer goods and stolen
data so he's all sheet and this is all
on the dark web dark web yeah I'm very
curious how the drug delivery system
works like does it just come over like
an Amazon package I know like Amazon
fresh yeah cuz like you order it online
but I mean it could get caught in the
mail I'm also kind of scared like I'm
interested in the dark web but I'm
scared if I just even google it all of a
sudden I'm like on the FBI watch list or
something like any FBI agents out there
that's a fan can you let us know in the
comments like if I'm allowed to cool you
could you I did it you did it yeah I
checked out like where is the dark web
and like how do you get into and there's
YouTube videos too of just like people
like explaining what the dark web is how
you get there okay just like peek
without we can't do it art with our OS
cuz we're all on like oh we have to get
Linux or whatever and then you have to
connect in a different way oh well
that's good to know that it's hard okay
I don't know anything about the
interwebs so when he landed in Atlanta
he was immediately arrested
and then during a border search of his
laptop it confirmed his identity as oxy
monster which is the administrator in
that marketplace that you leave on
marketplace in the dark web they
arrested him and he the reason why he
was in Atlanta because he was going to
this beard convention how did they even
know like they were staking him out and
they're just waiting till he arrives the
investigators they tied his username or
like the you
oxi monster too Valerius is real
identity through his bitcoin
transactions and so again some of them
would go into bitcoin wallets that are
associated with his name and so by the
time like he landed here they were able
to get him that's some crazy-ass [ __ ] so
science you know this first time in the
US - oh that's suck as soon as you land
you're like America I'm gonna get
barbecue he's like video end up getting
to the beard competition no you couldn't
even get the gold airport they could've
at least let him gone to the thing no
wait on his way back
take him to the jail's that's not that's
not cool why I'd let him have fun cuz he
extradited himself that's the worst
place to get arrested
like our cops were so lazy that they
didn't even go to France to get him they
just like he's coming they're not lazy
they're smart maybe they can't be maybe
they can't go over there they can only
watch it's not your jurisdiction
oh yeah yeah that's always blocking
people in the movies man this is not
your jurisdiction go back they wanted to
grab him though because since he had
like an administrator role in that
market like he's pretty high up in that
entire so we can do that we can like
catch international criminals and put
them in our jails and all that stuff and
maybe here selling to US citizens the
people that arrest them are they for be
if it's for Baba idea I think they can
oh that's true because like on the moody
on the show like narcos that the air the
DEA agents they send tried to extradite
s' yeah there's so many people that
guess the extradite s-- America so
gangster you know it's crazy we are so
thug that we went into Panama and we
took the president and we brought them
back to the US put them on trial for
drug charges and then we incarcerated
him that's how powerful we are we could
go into other people's countries and
just take their presidents that's so
crazy you know because there's no yeah
cuz there's no way anybody could like if
Trump was under suspicion for drug
charges in the US right no
could play police like that take Trump
out of our country
and then like put them in their
country's court and jail them no one
could do that but we could do it that's
how that's how crazy it is hey was this
guy like did you have a lot of money or
like like was he like Pablo Escobar of
like interwebs well they're saying that
they've discovered about $500,000 in
bitcoins like on his laptop and [ __ ]
they just discovered I'm not sure
exactly where that sounds like a lot
though
half a million dollars so he would sell
oxycontin and Ritalin
with a little Ritalin I can't do it oh
he cares about kids with ADHD
and people that need painkillers yeah he
would that but then it was so yeah like
what he was selling wasn't as crazy like
heroin and chocolate oxycontin is her
own it's legal it's as heroin in a pill
form yeah yeah opiate it's not as strong
it's pretty strong you can't just take
the whole pill you got a slicing so like
for their eats I took it before I didn't
really do anything you probably got the
not the name brown ones all right or
maybe a low dosage yeah maybe not too it
depends on its shape they have different
dosage what is a triangle circle oh well
my roommate god I've never tried it
before so I tried it and then nothing
happened
I said tingly fingers no I went to sleep
maybe it was old or wasn't even that was
just Tylenol since when are you so
experimental I always try to put it in
your butt needle at me experiment well
you mean you're trying to act all
experimental and I like chemistry
experiments I want I can I could
definitely make I was Anatomy experiment
your way different chemistry experiment
oh I'll put some chemicals in you we're
in the [ __ ] know what you put in your
butt yeah if he lets me on the back what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you I'm gonna
slap him
yeah what I gots it so you're setting a
liver failure
yeah well he's been pressing oh
girlfriends and wives know when I got
sick um
I had like like I don't know some kind
of intestinal pain and [ __ ] like that
and my doctor he gave me some medicine
and they were torpedo shaped like a
bullet and I was supposed to stick that
up my ass
and I I think I was like 11 or something
at the time oh no oh yeah a tiny gentle
little [ __ ] right I'm sitting there
in it like goes up halfway and it gets
shot out like a [ __ ] pad like my
[ __ ] ass rejects it good job I put I
put it back in
I once got it in and immediately just
like pumps out like I push it back out
and I'm like mom I can't do this I
[ __ ] re-entered this piece of Dookie
medicine over and over and I can't do
this so I gotta take medicine like
orally I can't I'm not so you smaller
girl after they come in individual you
got to pop it out and it's in the shape
it's like it's like in the shape of a
bullet like this what you end up doing I
didn't take the medicine they give you a
shot yeah I asked for them to just give
me like medicine that I can drink or
whatever I've never had to take it you
just size it a certain like you're
pushing you ever took a pill in your ass
no it hurts
maybe well you're a little you did it I
remember my my doctor was trying to do
it he couldn't do it yeah and then my
dad end up doing it and I hurt like a
mother I remember quarreling yeah yeah
the doctor tried to and then it just
shot right out I was like I don't want
to do it I don't want to do it it just
hurt yeah maybe I was younger than 11 I
maybe I was like you know yeah I mean
since what everyone went through or is
it just no no even if you get stomach
problems and if you get sick in a bit I
don't know I think at some point yeah I
don't know what sickness I had bouts at
the hospital that's some weird-ass [ __ ]
I only got a shot on my ass and that's
about it
I remember the suppository I think it
was like for a fever a pill up your butt
for a fever I remember something like
that
but you are really little right so maybe
I wasn't ten or eleven maybe I was way
younger this is that a mexican pharmacy
that doctors you guys going see was it
different
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
just kidding News and if you did really
enjoy it or if you have thoughts about
what you just watched
leave a comment down below and let us
know and for the next video click right
up here
[Music]